[Música]
el huracán salida degradado a tormenta
tropical provocó inundaciones
catastróficas en los estados de alabama
y florida y deja más de medio millón de
hogares sin electricidad ahora avanza
hacia el norte y se espera que este
jueves deje también fuertes lluvias e
inundaciones en estados como georgia y
las carolinas
con más de seis millones seiscientos mil
casos y más de 196 mil muertes
el presidente de donald trump prometió
100 millones de dosis de vacunas contra
el cob y 19 antes de las elecciones de
noviembre contradiciendo la opinión de
los expertos mientras que en europa la
transmisión es alarmante según afirmó ms
tenemos reporte
la policía griega comenzó a trasladar a
migrantes al nuevo campo de refugiados
de riesgos sin embargo la mayoría de los
migrantes se niega a instalarse en el
nuevo recinto porque temen quedarse
bloqueados durante meses a la espera de
un posible traslado hacia el continente
u otro país europeo
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 comenzamos este
informativo con el huracán salida de
grado a tormenta tropical que causó
estragos en eeuu el fenómeno tocó tierra
este miércoles cerca de gulf shores en
alabama donde dejó al menos un fallecido
y sigue causando inundaciones históricas
en el sur de este estado y en el
noroeste de florida según información
del centro nacional de huracanes angela
comenzó a ampliar información
las autoridades de florida informaron de
daños en infraestructura y cortes del
suministro eléctrico que iniciaron antes
del impacto con más de 570 mil hogares
afectados para los ciudadanos las
fuertes inundaciones fueron sorpresivas
no estábamos demasiado preocupados
porque seguían diciendo que iba a ser
una categoría 1 y cuando llegó fue una 2
había mucho viento mucha lluvia
en alabama cerca de 300.000 se quedaron
sin electricidad y en misisipí los
puntos afectados se acercaron a 10.000
sin embargo los daños no fueron tantos
como se esperaba
si van a pasar ya sabes dos o tres
semanas antes de que todo vuelva a la
normalidad pero no hay ningún daño
importante salida es el primer huracán
que toca tierra en alabama desde 2004 y
las inundaciones que trajo consigo
fueron calificadas de repentinas y
catastróficas todavía se teme por
posibles desbordamientos de ríos e
incluso tornados en algunas partes del
noroeste de florida el sur de alabama y
el suroeste de georgia en el golfo de
méxico tras tocar tierra con vientos de
casi 165 kilómetros por hora la tormenta
presenta ahora vientos máximos
sostenidos de 110 kilómetros por hora
mientras continúa su trayectoria hacia
el sureste de alabama y el extremo
noroccidental de florida para este
jueves se terminará como depresión en la
costa de las carolinas
salí fue el octavo huracán de esta
temporada en el atlántico y actualmente
hay otras tres tormentas activas lo que
hace de 2020 uno de los años con más
fenómenos registrados
seguimos en eeuu pero hablemos ahora de
la situación del joven 19 en ese país
porque contradiciendo a los expertos de
su propia administración el presidente
de donald trump aseguró que antes que
finalice este 2020 el país contará con
100 millones de dosis de vacunas contra
él con 19 andrés amaya nos explica
ante un comité del senado el director
del centro para el control y prevención
de enfermedades de eeuu robert redford
responde a la pregunta sobre cuándo
habrá una vacuna disponible para todos
los ciudadanos estadounidenses
y creo que habrá una vacuna que
inicialmente estará disponible en algún
momento entre noviembre y diciembre pero
un suministro muy limitado y tendremos
que tener prioridad
si me preguntan cuándo estará disponible
en general para el público
estadounidense de modo que podamos
comenzar a aprovechar la vacuna para
volver a nuestra vida normal creo que
probablemente estamos hablando de
finales del segundo trimestre o tercer
trimestre de 2021
poco después el presidente de donald
trump contradijo el director del centro
sanitario prometiendo que para antes de
que finalice el año en el país serán
distribuidas 100 millones de dosis de
una vacuna contra el joven 19 y hemos
fabricado todos los suministros
necesarios para que tan pronto como la
fd apruebe la vacuna y como saben
estamos muy cerca de ello podamos
distribuir por lo menos 100 millones de
dosis para finales de 2020 y un mayor
número muy pronto monitorea el candidato
demócrata a la presidencia joe biden lo
atacó
seamos claros confío en las vacunas
confía en los científicos pero no confío
en donald trump y los estadounidenses
tampoco pueden confiar en él en este
momento tiene a qué tipo qué medida el
afán del presidente parece estar ligado
a intereses electorales cuando faltan
menos de dos meses para los comicios
presidenciales en los que se juega la
reelección por ahora las farmacéuticas
pzifer modernas y astrazéneca llevan a
cabo estudios de la vacuna que ya está
en la fase 3 pero aún no han entregado
su producto a la administración de
alimentos y medicamentos de ese país que
debe dar su visto bueno y garantizar la
seguridad del producto y según la
organización mundial de la salud de la
transmisión de el coronavirus en europa
es alarmante vamos hasta españa el país
más afectado por la segunda ola de
contagios de coronavirus que sufre
europa y donde se contabilizaron 4.728
nuevos casos en las últimas 24 horas y
366 muertes en los últimos siete días
más temprano conversamos con nuestra
corresponsal rosa pérez que nos explicó
la situación en el país veamos
veamos la situación en las calles desde
una relativa normalidad a pesar de las
restricciones y del uso generalizado y
obligatorio de la mascarilla en todas
partes eso sí veamos las cifras españa
es el noveno país del mundo donde se han
contabilizado más casos positivos de
coronavirus pero las autoridades alertan
de que no se pueden comparar fácilmente
las cifras de un país con otro porque no
todos los estados utilizan el mismo
método ni hacen el mismo número de tests
pero en españa se han contabilizado
desde el inicio de la pandemia más de
600.000 casos positivos de coronavirus y
en las últimas dos semanas se han
contabilizado de estos 600.000 más de
100.000 pero hay que tener en cuenta que
también se hacen muchísimas más pruebas
pcr de las que se hacían por ejemplo
durante la primavera y que es también
por eso que hay un crecimiento
exponencial de las cifras pero lo que
preocupa por ejemplo a la organización
mundial de la salud es que de estos
tests masivos que se están llevando a
cabo sale un índice de positividad de
alrededor de un 15% y la organización
mundial de la salud indica que para
tener una pandemia en situación
esta cifra tendría que estar por debajo
del 5 pero por otro lado si miramos los
fallecimientos del último día del que se
tienen cifras del 15 de septiembre los
fallecidos fueron 17 y pensemos que en
los momentos más duros de la pandemia
aquí en españa esta cifra llegó a
alcanzar las 900 personas fallecidas en
un día por kobe 19 y cambiamos ahora de
información la policía griega está
llevando a cabo una operación en la isla
griega de lesbos para trasladar a miles
de migrantes y refugiados a una nueva
instalación unas 12.000 personas han
estado durmiendo en la intemperie
después de que un incendio destruyera el
asignado campamento de memoria hace una
semana sin embargo muchos refugiados se
muestran reacios a trasladarse
vestidos con trajes protectores blancos
la policía griega intenta convencer a
los refugiados de que se instalen en el
nuevo campo en la isla de lesbos la
agencia de la onu para los refugiados
acogió la operación con satisfacción
diciendo que unos 11.000 solicitantes de
asilo siguen durmiendo en la intemperie
mientras sea pacífico creemos que es un
buen movimiento considerando que aquí en
la calle es un riesgo para la seguridad
para la salud pública y no es la
dignidad que necesitamos para todos
el nuevo campamento tiene una capacidad
para unas 8000 personas a los recién
llegados se les está haciendo la prueba
de coronavirus con docenas de resultados
positivos hasta el momento las
autoridades griegas arrestaron a seis
jóvenes afganos en relación con el
incendio carrazo moria el mayor campo de
refugiados de europa la noche del 8 de
septiembre dejando unos 12.000
refugiados sin hogar la policía dice que
han estado usando la persuasión en vez
de la fuerza para trasladar a la gente
al nuevo campamento en un sitio no muy
lejos de donde una vez estuvo moría sin
embargo muchos son reacios a ir temiendo
que se les dejara esperando durante
meses para que sus solicitudes de asilo
sean procesadas
no iré porque es como una prisión ya
nada
bromatología dicen que todos los que se
mudaron al nuevo campamento han huido de
él después de una sola noche one light
de la nave
grecia ha pedido durante mucho tiempo
más solidaridad por parte de otros
países de la unión europea alegando que
no se debe dejar que tenga toda la carga
de la migración del continente pero
del incendio sólo alemania ha ofrecido
reubicar a un número sustancial de
refugiados
y en venezuela un día después de
conocerse del informe de una misión de
naciones unidas que acusaba al gobierno
de nicolás maduro de crímenes de lesa
humanidad las reacciones y críticas han
sido permanentes este organismo señala
que como política de estado se han
registrado ejecuciones extrajudiciales
torturas y desapariciones forzadas
cargando contra la oposición
el canciller jorge arreaza dijo que está
plagado de falsedades para analizar lo
que ocurre en venezuela respecto a los
derechos humanos quiero saludar en este
momento a rafael ramírez el ex embajador
de venezuela ante naciones unidas y ex
presidente de petróleos de venezuela
señor ramírez gracias por atendernos en
france24 le pregunto qué opinión le
merece este informe de la onu donde
detallan graves violaciones a los
derechos humanos y además lo más
preocupante con el conocimiento del
estado y la justicia del país
sí gracias por la oportunidad bueno un
informe demoledor es un informe que
viene a constatar y documentar lo que
han sido nuestras denuncias permanentes
que el gobierno nicolás maduro ha
convertido la represión y violación de
los derechos humanos en una política de
estado
fíjate que este informe tiene dos
vertientes una es la represión política
de la que hemos sido objeto todos
nosotros yo me estoy exiliado por
ejemplo pero otro ha sido lo que me duró
emprendido una especie de limpieza
social donde se han reportado en seis
años más de 24.000 ejecuciones
extrajudiciales que el gobierno dulce
que son de resistencia a la autoridad
ahora hablemos de otro tema que aquejan
a los venezolanos y de nuevo ese es uno
de los problemas principales del país la
falta de gasolina usted toma
expresidente de pvc de petróleo de
venezuela que es lo que ocurre
exactamente en un país con una de las
reservas de petróleo más grandes del
mundo
sí bueno maduro intervino a partir del
año 2014 pedevesa bueno han salido más
de 100 mil trabajadores nos persiguió
nos exilio hay más de 150 gerentes
presos secuestrados sin derecho a la
defensa y sencillamente nuestras
operaciones se han venido al piso pues
no en el año 2014 que fue mi último año
de gestión en agosto del 2014 en nuestro
país producía 12 millónes de combustible
atendíamos al mercado interno con
600.000 verbenas y exportábamos 400.000
barriles diría de combustibles gasolina
dice es decir en 6 años no solamente las
refinerías están paradas sino que la
producción hoy día está apenas en 340
mil barriles de petróleo en la misma
producción que teníamos en 1930 maduro
ha intervenido pérez a la militar hizo a
partir del año 2017 y ha desviado sus
recursos para otros propósitos ahora
cómo se pueden normalizar entonces la
situación del combustible en venezuela
es tremenda porque este el problema es
que nuestras refinerías que tienen una
tremenda capacidad instalada no están
operando ni siquiera tiene un suficiente
petróleo para alimentar las refinerías
entonces maduro ha tenido un pésimo una
pésima gestión al frente a la empresa y
la empresa pedevesa es muy compleja
ellos el de ellos no es para estar
improvisando no y ahora se vino al piso
punto cero no saben qué hacer con la
situación pero eso tiene en el país
block down permanente en una comuna
encerrados por el coronavirus porque no
tienen manera de garantizar el
combustible para el movimiento a la
gente pues no hay combustible en el país
no se produce no solamente no hay
combustible sino que no hay gas tampoco
la gente está cocinando con leña lo cual
era algo absolutamente absurdo en el
2014 eso no era así para nada y
colombiano sabe bien y en su opinión
cómo se puede arreglar esta situación
que es grave para la movilización además
a los ciudadanos dentro del territorio
dentro de venezuela
si yo lo he dicho el problema de
pedevesa no es un problema no es un
problema técnico tenemos suficientes
capacidades tenemos la reserva de
petróleo más grande del planeta un
problema político pues maduro mientras
maduro esté al frente del gobierno
nosotros no vamos a poder rescatar
nuestra industria petrolera él ha
intentado privatizar la violan a
nuestras leyes pero ni siquiera los
privados quieren hacer parte de una
situación que absolutamente irregular y
que viola nuestras leyes nuestra
constitución hay un problema de fondo
político en el país que necesitamos que
cambie para recuperar nuestro país
nuestra constitución y nuestras empresas
pues cree que rápidamente una última
pregunta creo que esto le puede jugar en
contra al presidente maduro en las
elecciones parlamentarias de diciembre
esas elecciones están controladas por
maduro yo lo dije no se puede votar en
esta circunstancia y 47 millones
venezolanos que están fuera del país no
tenemos derecho al voto maduro controla
todo nada lo que se tiene que darse
cuenta el pueblo venezolano es que
debemos buscar la unidad de todos para
movilizando en contra un gobierno que ha
devenido una dictadura por señor ramírez
gracias por su tiempo por estar con
nosotros en france 24 que tenga usted un
feliz resto de ella y hasta aquí
entonces el informativo en nuestro canal
siga con nosotros para una nueva
actualización de noticias hasta pronto
[Música]